we got this from fox news parents
respond to doj school board statements
i am
i am what a domestic terrorist i am what
a domestic terrorist looks like that's
the quote all right doj issued memo
after nsba suggested school boards might
be facing domestic terrorism
this is amazing the doj basically came
out merrick garland and said that
they're going to be investigating claims
of harassment intimidation threats and
violence
even if
some one of these parents said these
school board meetings all right hold on
hold on let me slow down for those that
may be missing the context parents have
been protesting school board meetings
because they're demanding the schools
either stop masking their kids change up
the curriculum they're not happy with
critical theory critical race theory and
critical gender theory so things have
been getting intense
steve bannon i'll always shout him out
because he was the one who said this to
us and he deserves the credit that the
parents would revolt when they saw what
their what was happening to their kids
and boy was he right but i didn't expect
the federal government to react this way
let me guys let me ask you guys
something if uh say a fight broke out at
a bar do you think the fbi would get
involved negative no if like a guy
showed up to a golf game and got really
angry and started yelling at some other
guy and then hit him
literally hit the guy would the feds get
involved wait is there something
resembling a noose involved because if
there is then they might show up a lot
yes
that's true i mean it could swarm the
place the pole rope for the golf cart
the pool rope of course yes then the fbi
swarm then they're there
but for the doj to come out and be like
claims of local political harassment are
now federal jurisdiction
man did this strike a nerve yeah and
this is extremely political how else can
you say it i mean there's been videos
that have been going viral with people
finally finding out what's really
happening in the public schools or as
other people call them indoctrination
centers and they're livid and they're
angry and i i think they have a right to
be angry with what's been happening
because they have been using
institutions of learning to really
indoctrinate people into this subculture
that has been pushed as far as an agenda
and a narrative now the governor of
florida had a very interesting response
to this he just tweeted quote attorney
general garland is weaponizing the doj
by using the fbi to to pursue concerned
parents and silence them through
intimidation florida will defend the
free speech rights of its citizens and
will not allow federal agents to squelch
dissent that's what ron desantis just
said uh on his public twitter account
and i think he's definitely being the
front runner and someone who is trying
to set himself for the next presidential
election i dig it i dig it but let's
let's provide some help to all of you
who may have heard about critical race
theory i think most people who watch
this show probably have a good
understanding of what we mean when we
talk about critical race theory or
critical race applied principles because
we often get corrected by our own
audience the super chats but there may
be someone you want to share this with
and they're saying i heard on msnbc
there's no critical race theory in these
schools and these parents are freaking
out because the republicans made
something up
let's make it simple for you critical
race theory
in the literal sense refers to works by
like derek bell and kimberly crenshaw
literally kimberly crenshaw wrote a book
called critical race theory where she
talks about what it means and they
describe it as the the analysis of the
intersection of race and the legal
system is a simplified way of putting it
however critical race theory in practice
or praxis or critical race applied
principles are what people are
protesting at schools all of a sudden
their kids come home and say mom they
segregated us by race and the parents
say why and they say i don't know social
justice or something all of a sudden
we're learning about minority children
saying they feel less than they feel
like they aren't good enough and they're
told they can't be with their white
classmates now that's crazy in one
school the principal actually segregated
the black students from the white
students creating different classrooms
that's how insane this ideology has
become when parents hear that they say
naturally yo i'm not okay with this what
happens the propaganda machine of the
mainstream media and big tech comes out
and says there is no critical race
theory in schools critical race theory
is legal scholarly works that's taught
in college name one school teaching
critical race theory
there's dozens of books
there's probably hundreds of schools
because there's hundreds of protests but
they're doing what's called critical
race praxis what does that mean
instead of telling you here's what
kimberly crenshaw and derek bell have
said they'll give you a math problem
john is stopped by the police 17 times
per year but josiah has stopped 493 and
he'll show a picture of a white kind of
black eye they'll be like what percent
more or how many times more was you know
this you know josiah stopped they're
implementing these these ideological
narratives and this dogma into the
classwork parents are freaking out
now let's work it's crazy
harassment now i'll tell you this i
started this segment by by making this
sort of like joke right if there was a
fight at a bar would the feds get
involved okay let's say there were a
handful of bars across the country and
people were complaining about them you
know doing something objectionable would
the feds get involved with local
harassment
is is this really the job of the doj to
be like i heard that a parent was
harassing another parent
no that that's crazy yeah this this uh
what do you call it hate crime thing
this this new term that's being overly
used i think is is devastating because
the it gives the federal government
authority to like step in and make a
bigger deal out of something than
maybe what it actually was they can just
say
your intent was this therefore
you know how do you prove it's the
craziest thing that hate like hate
crimes because you know like crimes are
like indifference or hatred you know
what i mean like if a guy at a bar says
i hate you to a guy and then beats him
up how is that not a hate crime he said
it but it's not
it's not the definition of it which
makes no sense i don't get it man well
they're it's semantics when they say
hate crime right but what they're really
doing is saying
we can set harsher penalties based on
these criteria which is a form of
political persecution in my opinion and
it's racial segregation yeah you know it
is a problem when there's racists
attacking people based on their race or
homophobes or whatever
but at the same time
should the law be applied unequally to
different people
no i think the answer to that is no but
it's happening uh i think it's happening
more and more there's more documented
cases of this and i think within the
last few years we have seen the hyper
politization of the national security
state and that's extremely terrifying
because they're unaccountable they have
vast amount of power that they can't be
reined in they have unlimited black
budgets and they're using this power for
political purposes which they're not
supposed to be for a very specific
reason because when they do they become
the stasi the kgb and other very
political security agencies throughout
history that are very dangerous and
we're not there yet but i think we're
slowly heading in that direction no i
think you're wrong i think we're there
i think that the tactics have just
evolved you know we we often mention
yuri basmanov on the show and we get
people chatting us yuri basman of all
the time for those aren't familiar he
was former kgb he did an interview
talking about demoralization and he said
that a fully there could be an
individual that you could show the
actual evidence and factual information
and they will not accept it because they
are truly demoralized we're there
when i'm gonna i i you guys you know i
love the metric but when the democrats
say the economy is good
and by like no objective metric could
you say that
these people live in in in wonder world
they're lit a parallel reality of fake
news i mean look at let's go brandon
there was uh i actually was just on uh
newsmax with with sean spicer
and we were talking about how
joe biden made a comment about kirsten
cinema that oh you know it doesn't
happen when she got harassed they follow
him to the bathroom so it doesn't happen
to people with secret service ha ha nbc
news
played like a few seconds of the clip of
his quote and then cut off the rest i
don't think it's the most egregious
thing ever but it's an example of what
the media does
why couldn't the media just show the
extra three seconds of the clip so you
understood the full context of what
biden said they removed that because it
was a snooty remark from biden about
doesn't happen to people with secret
service or something that affect
so what the people who watch the
mainstream media or msnbc or nbc live in
a very carefully crafted reality where
donald trump is is is evil where steve
bannon is a nazi when the dude literally
says tax the rich and these were the
agencies that were lying through their
teeth just a few years ago telling us
russia's involved telling you russia
hacked this election where was the
evidence and then again
we found out everything that they said
was
lying through their teeth so the fact
that they're becoming more brazen in
their actions and that now that they're
focused on on parents because you could
see that the parents have been making an
effect here because
you can't take over a nation if you
can't indoctrinate the next generation
and we're seeing a very significant
pushback which
shows you that that has a lot of power
since the fbi is literally tasked with
trying to uh you know intercept it and
investigate it as much as they can so it
shows you that on one hand yes this is
egregious but on the other hand you know
little small actions like getting
involved in your community are
absolutely critically important that's
the thing so what do you do with these
parents that aren't buying this
cathedral narrative i mean the only
option it seems to me is that they're
going to be branded terrorists and
that's the thing about garland's letter
is that like i mean harassment okay
intimidation whatever but he says
threats of violence that's the key
phrase that he's using to really isolate
these people as being dangerous and
they're dangerous or they're perceived
as being dangerous to people like him in
the cathedral because they're not buying
the narrative they're not going along
with it and they're just not yeah so the
terrorists they're terrorists yeah
that's that's the only that's the only
way to categorize them at this point
right if you don't if you have hammers
and and you produce hammers you need
nails so the national security state
literally is looking
begging for their next boogie man and
and uh wrong excuse me excuse me excuse
me
antifa
antifa it's at the right there
if they want an excuse they can be like
look at this building that got burned
down they can go no it's ideological of
course yes and that's why they need
their latest nail that goes along with
the bigger house crap house that they're
building uh
antifa is not the kind of terrorism they
need it's the kind of terrorism they
have well they push their agenda and
their narrative they need white
nationalism this is something they've
been claiming is a huge issue in the us
and it's not yeah they're like where do
we get it from where can we fight ever
since we saw the rise of the national
security state after 9 11 i always was
warning my audience members hey look out
because this will be turned inward
against the american people and the war
on terror will become a war on the
people and we're at this phase right now
at this very moment when they're going
after people in school boards are you
kidding me it's ridiculous the parents
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you